hello and welcome to this video playing
a riverboat cow yeah this is a try to
play chess and roughly 7:00 in the
morning which didn't work out well in
the two games before I hope I'm doing
better in the third game well seem yeah
the Petrosian is a good line for 7:00 in
the morning as some yeah sometimes you
get really simple to play positions I
could be one of those it's already a
fairly bad line for black with yeah it's
not touristy tricking the Kings Indian
you always have to kill more than one
one time in a game yeah you you usually
get to often get a position RAM yeah
you're just strategically clearly better
like him that that's already
strategically terrible for black but
then you still have to win it by tactics
and because black is doing all kinds of
things to muddy the waters so let's see
what happens him black kind of has to
play that so that he has at least some
kind of idea in the game with f5 but
it's it's it's just not good right I
mean you don't want to be in the
situation with black so anyway let's see
what to do here rook g1 as possible even
Bishop g4 it's it's kind of normally you
don't get this actually you don't manage
the smooth Knight to e4 is of course
also quite good
94 he will probably play Knight to f6
Luke g1 is another move that is kind of
tempting let's do this I'm not quite
sure what its best here to be honest it
looks som like white is better in more
than one way let's let's do this
Queen age form is the move that is the
most desirable let's say but didn't go
for it
so here how do we how do we get down
I mean a Queen to h5 or something would
be good for the attack and I want to
cast along here of course castle Castle
queenside
and 90 to e4 maybe a son I have six and
somehow somehow it continues he has
night before sometimes okay I'm going to
play this now I just don't want to take
any longer and then get into into time
time issues
so yeah just this one trying to play it
and in a somewhat simple Wayne Queen d2
will be a useful move next attacking age
six well that's odd I thought he needs
to go to g6 so that King age 7s is
possible right okay we'll see maybe he
has some idea with night before yeah so
castling queenside you know you have to
be a knight a two would be checkmate
yeah so you have to be a little bit
alert but I mean black blacks King
position is clearly the more problematic
of the two but still anyway so what now
Bishop h6 don't see why not
okay so now how do we how do we win this
night-night
d3 assesses on the cards I have Knight
f5 actually it's because of the pennant
and where is the Queen going local g7
next looks pretty awful and I didn't see
that move coming I can take here right
so I should win the Queen yeah it was
just like a completely unplayable
positional the opening from like I did
it it's it's rather it's a it's not
uncommon young people don't really know
how to play against the Petrosian I
always see that I always see that
happening is wrong but I see that
happening really frequently Knight a6 is
possible it's it's it's sometimes you
just slightly inaccurate you want to
play h6 first and get the bishop to h4
now I can get to e3 which is considered
to be yeah more desirable square than h4
yeah and now I'm like it needs to be
really precise and I think this is
already not cutting it after G form how
do you ever get played I mean if you go
f5 you see what happened in the game
that wasn't easy for like but you cannot
just stay and do nothing I mean slow
moves I'm going h4 h5 and get the
typical Petrosian clamp so yeah I
understand it that he wants to do
something so this is kind of what you do
and now I don't know what black should
do it doesn't feel like a good position
at all King h8 is also the engine move
yeah now I was unsure because everything
looks good somehow Bishop g4 looks like
a good move engine gives Bishop f3
that's bit odd for Bishop b4 maybe yeah
and my move now where the engine also
thinks my move is ok right if six looked
normal
Queen h4 is given as better still white
is quite solidly for choice so Knight f6
Knight g3 Bishop h7 Queen d2 it just
looks it looks bad yeah the engine gives
me a win based claim the form
yeah if I were what to do in h6 is just
gone on and Queenie 7-9 f5 is just over
I mean I g8 gave away the Queen but
there's just no move yeah look just
seven wins it took me a second - this is
winning him it would be the more another
most stylish way to finish the game at
the Petrosian is just a good opening I
mean I think that black probably should
equalize but it's not easy to do it's
really not easy to do okay guys thanks a
lot for watching